I can go back here this way.
Okay.
So this is...
You can play this one.
You can pause whenever you want.
Yeah.
So, you can pause.
The first setup was not strong enough, in my opinion here, and there should be more
pauses between moves.
I think the 8 seconds is still perhaps too fast.
Okay.
So now, I can go back to the first setup.
Each movement does not feel as strong in the video compared to when I was doing it.
Especially...
All the blocks and the punches and strikes need to be faster.
Okay.
And it felt strong when I was doing it, but I guess looking at the video it doesn't look as strong.
I'm going to do the same thing on the other side as well, but I'm going to do the same thing on the other side.